welcome to this video playing bad
Hedgehog that's a funny name Western
forest Europe ok that's a latvian flag
right yeah latvia very high rating here
this guy and so you're going to play a
Ben Oni maybe or the Blumenfeld know it
Ben Oni kind of a unusual move order
mm-hmm had that move order recently
against John Bartholomew and I went for
that thinking that it should be good but
John played Queen 85 and it was kind of
murky I'm still going for that ok he's
giving up this pawn I'm going to take it
and he needs to show me the compensation
there is very often there is one in
terms of dark square played these kind
of positions are this idea is known from
the our buck Kings Indian but this is
not exactly the our buck there are some
differences here I can maybe take c5
what is exactly the point Queen a five
probably four 94 so again you don't want
that one issue here can be that this
Bishop is some let's say place the Queen
route d 8 and the bishop can be in the
in the Queen some in the way of the
Queen let's say and then the D file can
be it can be tricky so going to go e 5
is going to play 97 probably so what are
we going to do here
if i move the bishop away that's route
28 and 94 coming 94 is always important
resource hmm so whatever am I doing here
queen bee 394 txt x95 heads it's kind of
messy not very nice actually mmm I don't
like the night coming to deform
absolutely not but rook da deserve is a
serious idea yeah yes very nice
compensation actually don't like this
position very much 495 I don't know if
this was a good solution but Tim wasn't
easy to play I rather would have played
against the bed Hedgehog against this to
make a little fun of his name him um k
95
where are you going with your queen now
sir Queen a6 there might be 97 ok now
nitey to check Queen c4 hmm but still
check
queen is six night CSM Bishop c4 stuff
okay now i can play b3 actually if i
want yeah I guess I want
Queen 86 97 is really just the exchange
there's no way around that if he goes to
a three I could have played Bishop see
one okay what about this I can take and
just play rook the one jack e five for
Bishop g5 I can go to Bishop g4 I am ok
he has that move that is probably
huidong Bishop to f4 to see three let's
go ahead for ya Bishop g4 what was
holding on ok let's still not so easy
there's still some some pinning issues
and some activity issues you can also
easily get the poem back ok
I mean tank either now come on let's
play quickly let's just play quickly gee
takes if I take everything and then at
the end rook to this have not sell
better end game right Queen takes Bishop
checks ok come on keep it simple okay
it's not taking which is probably the
right decision but here I am getting the
default
trying for up to seven this kind of
thing oh I did not look at that move at
all that was a mistake not checking that
hmm I should have at least looked at it
don't know how bad it is actually
because it has weakened f5 quite
enormously well it wasn't so good for
him
hmm
I don't see a complete win here time
warning should a trade or not trading
might be wrong Luke g6 as a move so
probably should get out of the G file I
am still in somewhat better here the
edge porn and so on
k wants to invade them
I'm going too slow I'm simply to slow
him
ah come on let me let me play a little
bit quicker here
of course I've lost the thread
completely with the time ticking down
chad's are really a shame getting to a
worse position after this totally
one-sided game but what can you do now
look see for now sure oh yeah okay come
on white ahead was really bad yeah that
was like giving giving the whole point
away on a silver plate okay let's let's
have a look at that Jack yeah I mean
losing I really should never do in this
position this is really odd hard to do
but let's let's see you around here okay
and how can you lose this end game
that's not easy it's not easy to do so
probably I should start with Bishop e3
here I mean but still Bishop f4 okay
it's okay i wanted to attack the h pawn
but this is just wrong right i should
just he has absolutely nothing he can do
i can just attack the pawns here and
yeah there was was the first first kind
of wrong move but you know it gets it
gets really bad him we should be aid
again better yeah and the way I played
it was how it was how horrible yeah
simply horrible rupee seven is still ok
for me even this still okay I just have
to be precise King you two or something
the point is not not promoting quickly
but this is this is completely losing
losing the threat jam just bad just
badly played it was interesting though
this is this position I think black has
very decent compensation it's just just
very difficult to to play I don't know
here this was interesting
he went here and 95 young and probably
he should be okay when he is if he is
precise like here he went to this is a
strange move because b 3 is clearly
beneficial for me i was thinking queen a
sick sister is the way to go something
like this and i couldn't really figure
that out it looks it looks a very funny
maybe i can move the Queen had the same
this is this is clearly clearly clearly
worse yeah yeah I'm really just a pawn
up and he has to struggle for
compensation if I've in fact was a bit
premature I should go I mean as a so
Bishop sorry not that so Bishop g4 too
late but I should just play probably
just the bishop out him and this isn't
enough not enough compensation the way
it when did was also a bit better but
not so decisive if he takes all the way
here it's a end game and that black has
to suffer maybe we're maybe we'll
success yeah like for a draw but it is
not not fun not at all here here yeah
probably i will remain with an extra
porn somehow but blackened blanket child
has chances to draw check just putting
some moves out here I don't know this is
enough to ever win for white I doubt it
some something like that is what what
you should do I guess yeah but okay if I
I just gave it away very very naively
this game okay thanks for watching